i'm kat timf i'm bill hemmer i'm harris
faulkner
and this is the fox news rundown
friday july 23rd 2021
i'm dave anthony senators keep trying to
work out a bipartisan infrastructure
compromise but many republicans are wary
the conversation that senate has been
having is about a wish list
of democrat priorities that i believe
make the american economy
less stable and will unemploy not
re-employ but unemploy
millions of americans we speak with
republican senator tim scott
and lisa brady two billionaires blast
off with their own rockets they got some
backlash here on earth but
is it the dawn of a new industry are you
going to say oh that's just a
that's just a sad nothing or you're
going to say did i just witness the
birth
of something that will transform
the future of civilization we speak with
famed astrophysicist
neil degrasse tyson and i'm rachel
campos-duffy
i've got the final word on the fox news
rundown
it stalled but the trillion dollar
infrastructure plan at the senate isn't
dead
even after republicans voted against
proceeding with minority leader mitch
mcconnell saying
around here we typically write the bills
before we vote on them senators in both
parties are still working on the
specifics but even if
it ultimately passes house speaker nancy
pelosi says
while we are eager for it to pass we
will not be taking it up
until the senate passes the
reconciliation bill
referring to the three and a half
trillion dollar plan democrats
have on their own for things like child
and health care
education and combating climate change
majority leader chuck
schumer and together they would give a
massive boost to the economy
ease inflation pressures create jobs
increase
productivity and reduce income
inequality
republicans disagree senator john
barrasso tells fox it's
the ultimate liberal wish list with
taxes and spending and regulations
that are not just reckless they're scary
when you really think about it
many republicans are also skeptical of
that first and smaller bipartisan
infrastructure plan
well there certainly seems to be some
interest in having another vote next
week so that tells me that some people
are still at the negotiating table
gop senator tim scott is from south
carolina
i will say that when asked to vote on
something without any legislation
without any text without any
understanding or appreciation
of what in a package how in the world
someone votes for that i have no idea
so i assume that by this time next week
we will have had an opportunity
to have greater eyes on the specificity
within the legislation now senator
the majority leader chuck schumer had
said listen this isn't a final version
we're just voting to proceed we can have
all kinds of amendments and we'll put
the bill together but we just want to
move forward
what is wrong with that approach why do
you not like his idea
well it's kind of like hitting a target
that you don't have or maybe even worse
spinning somebody around 20 times
in the middle of the dark and say please
hit the target
even though there are people standing
around you could do real
harm to the to the american economy to
the american people
if you are spending three and a half
trillion dollars or one trillion dollars
without any understanding or
appreciation of what it does
to the american people as opposed to for
the american people
and let's remember this is a group that
told us that they were putting together
a 1.9 trillion dollar
coveted relief package with only one
percent
going to vaccines and less than 10
percent going to covet related health
the level of confidence that i have in
this administration is very very low
what would you support if say there is a
vote next week
and the senate does go forward and
proceed what kind of a bill
will you say yes to well one of the
things i've said oftentimes
is in order to find a common ground you
have to have
common sense and there's not much common
sense in the middle of their overall
infrastructure approach their overall
infrastructure approach includes things
like
the pro act that eliminates the right to
work for 27 states
it compels or requires folks who are
working to pay
dues if there's a union present at their
employer
that is completely inconsistent with
common sense
however i would love to have a
conversation in a
silo from these policy positions
that the democrats want to lead us down
that road i'd rather have a conversation
about traditional infrastructure
broadband could be a part of that
conversation
roads and bridges airports and ports all
part of that conversation
that is not the conversation that we've
been having the conversation
that senate has been having is about a
wish list
of democrat priorities that i believe
make the american economy
less stable and will unemploy not
re-employ but unemploy
millions of americans all right now that
is what they say would be something
separate though right that
that human infrastructure as they call
it three and a half trillion dollars and
they have a lot of things they want to
do on that
that's through a reconciliation process
though that you would not be able to
block correct
of all 50 democrats and then the vice
president comes in
they can do existential harm to the
american economy and to the american
people without
question the vehicle of reconciliation
could allow them to do some things to
the american people
without us being able to block it the
good news is however
that when you're having a large broad
conversation about
their objectives the vehicle of
reconciliation
cannot be used for certain policy
positions
that's why the negotiation overall is
really
important to understand what's in it the
devil being in the details
is incredibly important when you have a
reconciliation vehicle
that can only be used for specific
revenue
items so they're going to try to push
through or push into other packages
things that we need to understand so any
rush to getting
this done without the ability to
understand every word in the
legislation could be very dangerous
to what we believe to be common sense
approach
on many of these issues your colleague
from south carolina
fellow republican senator lindsey graham
has said that maybe
in order to block something like that he
might not show up and then there
wouldn't be quorum
which sounds like something that texas
democrats did when they tried to block
the republican
voting reform bill is that something
that could be done is that something
that some republicans would support
i i have not uh i have not taken that
into consideration on what we could do
one thing i love about lindsey graham
he has a way of throwing jokes in the
middle of serious conversations to
lighten the mood
i can't imagine that happening i think
americans all across this country have
seen a
loss of income because of the biden
administration's
approach to things like inflation to
their approach to
covet relief so much money increasing
the demand
with a very small supply has led to
increases from
car rentals to used cars uh laundry
machines
to airfare to moving to hotels insurance
bacon tvs fruit shoes
all those things are up because of the
biden administration
inability to handle economic issues
the president does get pretty good marks
in different polls on his handling of
covid though
well if you're able to separate out the
warp speed that led to the fastest
delivery of a vaccine in human history
you can separate out
the five cares packages that were passed
under the previous administration of the
trump administration
the american people are not delineating
between 20 and 21 about what started
under president trump and what continued
under president biden
without that distinguishing of the
conversation of covet relief the fact
that we
are in much better shape today mostly
driven by the success
of yesterday uh it is it is uh
important for us to yes celebrate
success but b if we're going to figure
out who gets the
benefit or who gets appraised for that
success you're probably talking
more of the trump administration than
you are the bible administration
now to the issue of police reform at a
cnn
town hall wednesday night in ohio
president biden said
we have to change police conduct and the
president denies republican claims that
he and democrats want to defund
police i don't know any community
particularly the communities that are
in the most need and the poorest and the
most at risk that don't want police they
want police though
to look at them as equals senator tim
scott has been leading police reform
negotiations for republicans
last year it was certainly harder to
actually negotiate because
it became very apparent very quickly
that the democrats wanted the issue more
than the solution
they wanted to be able to have this as
an election year issue
it's one of the reasons why we never
brought resolution to some very
important issues and
frankly my colleagues on the right my
republican colleagues
have been quite supportive of our
approach to
police reform and the good news is for
the american people who are watching us
very closely
we are still at the table negotiating
but what we're not going to do
is we're not throwing police under the
bus we are not going to change the
qualified immunity
for individual officers we are not going
to look for ways to defund the police
we are actually going to refund the
police or we're not going to have a bill
i think i am i am thankful that there
are
people of good intention on both sides
of the aisle having this conversation
but my responsibility is to break the
concepts of the notions of
binary choices that don't exist you
don't have to choose between
communities of color and officers
choosing one
means choosing the other so there's no
doubt that we're going to do what is in
the best interest of law enforcement
and the community that they serve and
we're going to either get that done
by keeping people working together or
we're going to
not get it done at all i'm confident
that we will have
a resolution to this issue what we had
by the end of june was simply
an agreement on the framing as i had
hoped for and in july
writing the text it takes a long painful
process but
unfortunately we've had so little
legislating
that people don't remember what it looks
like this is a long process
and it should be because we are indeed
the saucer that cools the cup
senator you're running for reelection
you're already out there
i've seen stories you've raised about 10
million dollars already so far
where are you on this and why do you say
this is the last time
you'll run this is not my profession
this is a calling and
i believe that term limits are important
for every senator in my opinion
and i think that the best way to lead is
the lead by example and and
so i've made the decision before i
arrived at in the senate to only serve
up to two full terms i've served part of
one so i
i can't serve more than two full terms
based on my own commitment
and i'll serve those two terms if the
people of south carolina allow me to
and the grace of god of good health i
will hopefully have that chance to do so
uh finally we're running because we have
work that's unfinished on
my opportunity agenda we have expanded
opportunities under the previous
administration president trump and the
republicans we were able to
bring unemployment to the lowest levels
ever recorded in history for
african americans and hispanics a
70-year low for women at 3.5 percent a
50-year low
for all americans so continuing to work
on the economics is really important in
this nation an incentive-based economy
is incredibly
important we see the success of that
through opportunity zones
and then we have other issues that we
have to work on i i'd like to have
definitions like infrastructure mean
things like
our port south carolina port authority
needs the resources to continue to
expand our exporting
opportunities around the world we need
better roads and bridges uh
that's a that's a factor throughout this
nation so i'm going to continue to work
on the common sense
common ground issues that every american
that i've talked to
think are important and sometimes we
miss those
obvious things in washington you know
people keep bringing you up
for possibly a 2024 run for the white
house
something you would consider or what
well you know i'm a gamecock fan and one
of the things i've learned about
football is you take one saturday at a
time and if you want to be successful
there's no
reason to think about the next saturday
if you haven't won the one in front of
you so
my theory and i don't mean this to be
flippant but i mean to be to be sincere
the most important thing i can do to
continue to serve the people of south
carolina is to win in 2022
and if you can be successful with that
the good lord knows what's
next but my greatest joy professionally
has been to be the united states senator
for the great state of south carolina
and i hope to continue to do so
senator tim scott republican from south
carolina of course thank you very much
for joining us
god bless thank you
[Music]
this is rachel campos duffy with your
fox news commentary
coming up it was a launch
heard around the world
has cleared the tower
the first manned flight for blue origin
the space company launched by amazon
founder
jeff bezos what we're doing is
the first step was something big the
bezos flight which also included the
oldest and youngest ever astronauts
came less than two weeks after british
billionaire sir richard branson
rode his rocket into space each
describing it as a dream come true with
much more than personal meaning for the
future
though not everyone on social media
seems to agree
but the white house is on board and
investments in space
create jobs can improve life here on
earth through climate monitoring and
medical advancements just to name a few
spokeswoman jen saki says the ingenuity
of commercial partners will help the
country advance to its next stage of
space
exploration nasa is already using elon
musk's spacex for cargo flights to and
from the international space station
and musk doesn't intend to stop there so
it seems a new kind of space
race is well underway these are the very
first
baby steps necessary before you open an
entire new business category
right space tourism neil degrasse tyson
is an astrophysicist
cosmic queries author and host and the
director of new york's hayden
planetarium
now it would probably be more accurately
described as
rocket tourism right it's not often
anyone has ever launched in a rocket
with a countdown
and for me that would be a kind of an
exciting thing to participate in
but these are these are sub-orbital
flights where you go up just above
the tip of the atmosphere then you fall
back for a couple of minutes
your weightless and then when you re hit
the atmosphere
then your weight returns so it's a short
journey
but um i can imagine a day where you
have full
orbital uh space tourism as well as
possibly visiting
colonies on the moon so i'm all for it
i mean yeah it certainly sounds like
feels like
maybe kind of an icebreaker for the
public
even though technically another
billionaire
um had already you know who isn't a
household name had already been
in space again using the term space
loosely because they're they're barely
on the threshold as you say
um well i'm an astrophysicist so if
you're going to ask me about space
it's not going to be slightly above
earth's surface we're going to talk
about
you know moon mars beyond to the edge of
the universe
but i think it's the fact that people
are using the word space
signals a level of enthusiastic
forward thinking about where this
enterprise could ultimately
land figuratively and literally and by
the way
there's a lot of attention given unto
they being billionaires and as you
correctly noted
charles simone was one of the microsoft
billionaires
went into space uh some years ago bought
a seat on the
soyuz capsule and went to the space
station at a time when nasa was not
selling speeds so
that was sort of the earliest test cases
of space tourism
fact is if they weren't billionaires and
it was still happening
would then people be excited about it i
mean i think they're being distracted by
the fact that
billionaires are involved and it's
really just think about it as a new
kind of thing you might do when you go
on a vacation
that's all and it's the beginning of it
how often do you get to see the
beginning of an entire industry
it's like watching the first ford model
t roll off the assembly line
we're watching the you know the earliest
right flyer
airplane right and are you going to say
oh that's just uh
that's just a fad no no or you're going
to say did we did i just witnessed the
birth
of something that uh will transform
the future of civilization well because
they're billionaires
they actually ended up getting a fair
amount of negative publicity
you know people essentially saying oh
look at these billionaires racing to
space
in their own rockets i mean could that
could this backfire instead of creating
more enthusiasm for space
tourism could this have the opposite
effect
yeah so there's a little bit of
backfiring there i i like the fact that
they put their own
literal skin in the game to demonstrate
the safety and the
and the and the reliability of their
hardware because i i had
joked with elon you know people said if
vlog wants to send you to mars would you
go and i joked and i said
not until he sends his mother and brings
her back safely
then i'll go so under those conditions
yeah i would
say if they if they put their own life
at risk to do this
then and they've got a lot to lose um
given the size of their wealth and their
kingdoms and whatever else they run
um that's a testament to i think how
safe it would be for the rest of us
the white house spokeswoman jensaki has
called this a
moment of american exceptionalism and
she talks about the importance of space
travel
to help fuel advancements here on earth
does the government need to do a better
job of telling that story because
when most people use something like gps
they're probably not thinking hey this
came from the space
program yeah in fact even when they're
not using gps
well even when they don't know that
they're using gps right
imagine telling the original gps
inventors do you know
one day people are going to use your
satellites
to find a mate within 100 yards of where
they're standing
by swiping right this is this is
you know who would have thought that
this is how we would be using space
technologies
uh point is the the uh by the way i'm a
scientist and
scientist is fundamentally not only
international but
literally universal so i don't like
thinking of american exceptionalism the
way others do
i think of human exceptionalism these
are these are human achievements
and um by the way we did send people
into low earth orbit
60 years ago alan shepard among them
so people shouldn't think of this as
breaking new
space ground what they're doing is
thinking about it in a whole other way
that people had not thought about it
before
and that is in the context of space
tourism well i guess the question
becomes you know how long until space
tourism might be
for everyone or at least let's say an
expensive trip for a family or a couple
who wants an
out of this world honeymoon or you know
how long
until it becomes at least a little
more commonplace or accessible however
you want to put it never and
some people are are angry because it is
like
billionaire joyrides in ways that none
of us will ever participate but i think
that's short-sighted and it misses
some important lessons from history an
example i like to give is
is from the the 1987 film wall street
um i don't know if you've ever seen that
or remember there's a scene where gekko
he's the rich bad guy right uh he's at
his hamptons
beach house and he's walking on the
beach
holding and speaking through his
shoulder-mounted
cell phone that's how big it was but i
remembered
i said wow i was i was rich so i can
have a phone
and walk on the beach and talk through
it but really the phone wasn't very good
it was big and clumsy and heavy
yes but you need to be rich to talk
through it once that
technology became commoditized now
basically everybody has a cell phone
almost everybody
and so and it doesn't cost whatever it
costs gekko
to speak through that one and and so for
something to become a true
industry it's got to reach for everyone
and the past history
especially when it's technologically
driven has indeed accomplished that
so what has to happen here is you get
more companies in the mix
you fly you fly the rockets multiple
times a year
dropping the amortized cost per launch
and then you get it down from a quarter
million or whatever it was there yeah
200 000
down to maybe a hundred thousand and in
economic terms the demand for this is
elastic
so whatever you had for 200 000 you
might have twice as many people
who'll do it for a hundred thousand how
about fifty thousand
ten thousand five thousand all right
i would save up several vacation
costs you know what's it cost to take
the whole family to fly to orlando and
go to disney
world okay that's that's a lot of money
especially if you buy
food there right so you have this huge
ticket
and they say okay i can go disney world
or i can go into orbit or into
into space and i think when you have
that kind of choice
um you'll see many more people flocking
towards this as a new kind of option for
it i know spacex
is expected to send up a ship in
september within
all civilian crew and that trip is
expected to last
a few days instead of a few minutes
would you be excited about that
well so for me uh i'm again i'm an
astrophysicist so when i think of space
and space travel
i'm not thinking of boldly going where
hundreds have gone before
in low earth orbit if you're going to
put me into space send me somewhere
the moon mars and beyond and elon has
been talking about
going back to mars forever okay so
that's where i would probably sign up
otherwise
no no i'm staying on earth
one more question for you i there will
probably always be
people who say space travel in general
but especially
the idea of space tourism is a waste
maybe the money's you know better spent
elsewhere what do you say to that
so it'd be something different if we
were only spending money on space
and not on everything else but we're
also spending money on
everything else so so it's just that
space is
really visible and garners headlines so
it
leaves you thinking why are we doing
that when we should be doing this
all right i remembered people would log
that complaint about nasa for example
you know why are we putting you know men
on the moon
okay well what are we what are we
spending to put men on the moon
and on average it was two at the time
two three percent of the federal budget
was engaged in sending astronauts to the
moon so you're going to look at that
and say we shouldn't spend that we
should then solve poverty or
homelessness
what about the 98 of the rest of the
budget
okay you're you're focusing on this two
percent
and saying that's wrong and not even
paying attention to the rest of the 98
of the federal budget
that's going to all manner of things in
this in this country
so i think that the answer here is
you want a balance of what activities
you engage in
in the world is anyone looking at a
public art project in the middle of a
square and say
this is a waste of money it's not
putting food on people's plate why
no you you choose art because it makes a
country worth defending
that you have people going into space
and creating art
and composing music and doing all of
these things
that enrich your senses and what it is
to be human
uh what you want to do is you do it all
and
i think we can and in many ways i think
we are
well thank you very much for always
broadening our
horizons neil degrasse cosmic
perspective
i and all my colleagues would tell you
exactly the same thing
neil degrasse tyson thank you very very
much for your time
you got it
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network
subscribe and listen to the trey gowdy
podcast
former federal prosecutor and four-term
u.s congressman from south carolina
brings you a one-of-a-kind podcast
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
rate and review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
[Music]
genshu price is on a mission
he's a middle schooler in hawaii who
started his own recycling program
it began with a suggestion from his dad
it was my dad's idea to collect cans and
bottles to help fund my college tuition
and then i figured i could make it into
something bigger and help other
hawaiians instead
audio courtesy of bottles for college
with his parents help and on occasion a
few volunteers
genshu collects hundreds of recyclable
donations each week
separating and sorting them before
dropping them off at a local redemption
recycling center
we want to create a system where
your at least yearly we can send one to
two kids and a fully funded right to
college so that will take
two to four million cans and bottles
it's a work in progress but he's already
collected more than a hundred thousand
cans and bottles
there's just so many things that he's
learning from this experience
and so we believe this is part of his
education
that's his mom maria genshu is thinking
big
so far they've got two permanent school
drop-off locations with one of them
being his own middle school
s.w king intermediate school where
they've also held large drop-off events
one of our goals is to get public
drop-off depots at every public school
in hawaii
so we have two of the public schools
right now and then we're hoping to
expand that way we have
a deep one every community that way that
every community can come and support
he says he'll keep working toward his
goal it's definitely exciting
and like it's just like every can counts
one cannonball time tanya j powers
fox news
it's time for your fox news commentary
rachel campbell's duffy
what's on your mind if you spend time
with cuban and venezuelan catholics
you will hear about the pain inflicted
on them by the man who's supposed to be
their shepherd
pope francis the heartache and betrayal
felt by faithful catholics many of whom
risked or continued to risk their
livelihoods and their lives to practice
and hold on to their faith in christian
traditions
is the reason so many freedom-loving
catholics have dubbed the argentine pope
papache after the iconic communist
murder
check avada it was more than a week
after protests spontaneously erupted
across the island of cuba
before papache said a word about the
courageous demonstrators
following a brutal crackdown of these
freedom protests heartbreaking video and
images emerged
of teenagers being dragged from their
homes in front of their crying parents
and faced with the impossibly cruel
choice of joining the military
to fight against their families and
their own liberation
or be sent to the gulags while brave
cubans were being rounded up by the
government's merciless
secret police pope francis found time to
make a statement
about racism in the soccer world cup but
not a word
about the human rights abuses in cuba it
was like a knife
to the heart it's hardly lost on cubans
living on the prison island
or the millions of cubans in exile
across the world that pope francis isn't
exactly known for holding his tongue
he publicly weighs in on virtually every
social justice issue under the sun
even those that challenge church
orthodoxy
in spite of the incriminating evidence
against cuba's communist regime
pope francis could only muster a
half-hearted comment this week
in his weekly vatican address about
being close
to the cuban people and a lame call for
peace and dialogue
cubans are right to wonder whether the
pope cares more about plastics in the
ocean
than the bodies of thousands of
desperate love fox news click the
subscribe button to get more of the news
and opinion you trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes